30 years of doing this what have you
learned about
men what have you learned about human
beings
30 years of doing this they're evil
honestly i didn't need to be in the
police to work some of that out but you
know there are some evil people out
there and
we use a phrase i said i used it earlier
and are they mad or are they bad you
know and there are some very very bad
people out there and
i don't think any of them are
trustworthy
if i'm honest with you anybody
no look
why do i
i said that's a real sweeping statement
but
when you say something don't say
anything and you know full well you're
feeding that in because they'll go and
tell somebody
you start to get the rub around human
nature don't you and that
most people don't do it for any bad
reason but yeah you've got it you've got
to be careful how many times have you
been married how many times have you
been married
once
and you're still married to the same
person
what do you what do you do when you're
talking to your wife and you're like
babe i know you're bullshitting me do
you colorado or you just kind of like
what do you do what do you do when that
happens do you just not say anything
she just got back she just got back in
um
no i mean i mean you know what i'm
saying sometimes
[Laughter]
paul miller has been missing for two
weeks yeah
yeah
you know i've got i've got two wonderful
sons but you know what i'm saying like
what i'm saying is like you know
sometimes i'm
i'm into i've been in sales for 20 years
and i've had a lot of weird people in my
life who are bipolar and personality
disorders and i've been forced to study
body language because i don't have a
choice i had to know a person who's got
seven different personalities every day
i had no idea who this person was going
to be so i'm like who are you today i'm
like okay let me pivot right but when
you when you're a parent now and you got
kids and you're married and you know
nobody walks on water when your kid lies
to you your spouse lies to you somebody
is maybe not wanting to tell you the
whole story and you know it and you read
it what do you do about it
try and keep a lid on it
it's
difficult the worst thing is when you
know and i still find it now i run a
business now i run a company that um we
recruit cops
so when cops retire we recruit them into
the public or private sector we've got a
services site so people have got their
own businesses they advertise us a few
pounds a few dollars a month
but i still get to the point when
someone says if someone walks into your
office and says you know what i've
really messed up here
you can almost forgive them you can
actually say okay as long as they tell
you the truth should they walk in and
say it wasn't i never did it
and that's you know your first instinct
is to go off like we have a phrase here
go up like a toughney rocket and
it's just
yeah i can explode sometimes i know you
find that hard to believe but i i have
got so i can get quite animated but
i suppose that's that's a passion yeah i
i guess the reason i'm asking this
question is like you know uh uh to be
doing this business and you're still
married to the same how many years have
you guys been married you said grandkids
so i'm assuming okay 30 years i mean
you have to know for 30 years you've
been dealing with people who cheat lie
steal kill
and
and you're trying to come home and say
babe how are you oh my gosh kids daddy's
here to play with you how you doing did
you do your homework of course i did my
homework you're like you know this kid
didn't do his homework so how do you how
do you not bring your work home
with what you do on a daily basis
my kids knew when i was on the major
investigation side my kids knew where i
was by the news because
the county is the the department we were
on was quite small so if there was a
homicide murder
um it would make the national news or
the you know the local news most
certainly so my kids knew and i was
quite an errant father i see this this
is a true story my son
um plays field hockey he's six foot five
he's
he's he's a giant now but plays field
hockey i know that you don't play field
hockey out there guys don't play field
hockey out there and he got through to a
national final
and i was in washington dc with the fbi
academy um doing a job there
i should have been at home i should have
been at home i should have been watching
my son play hockey um
and
you know i'm doing it all by the phone
how'd he get on yeah he did really well
you know you just
i missed out so much but here's the
other thing of that story
i traveled out there with a single pubic
hair um a young girl been
been
sexually assaulted
and a single pubic hair was found on her
underwear
and we'd identified the suspect's dna
the whole whole nine yards but they
brought into doubt how she collected
this on her body
so we went and found a scientist that
the fbi um
in quantico we went up there
fascinating guy a guy called carrion you
you couldn't wish to meet a nicer guy
but more interesting he's he's the man
who found the um
the blood or the fibers on the on the
break of the murder victim in in
texas when they dragged the black guy
behind the truck and he found
microscope a microscopic piece of debris
and they and they linked that car to the
murder of that guy absolutely
fascinating black anyway we go over
there
with a single pubic hair
i wasn't allowed to fly down to my
family holiday
in florida my parents had a house in
florida at the time i had to fly all the
way back to the uk for one day
and then fly back to the states after
the kid by the way who sexually
assaulted the girl he got found not
guilty by the by the court by the jurors
they they couldn't decide how that hair
was found on her on the inside of her
clothing attached to her body
he said that he'd urinated in a
particular place the hair had been
secreted it went onto her
inside of her clothing
blah blah blah anyway
did the kid ever commit another crime
later on in life or no he got locked up
he in fact within three days he went out
committed a robbery and he got locked up
for five years
good
um
we get on a plane flying down florida
usa into charlotte from charlotte down
to um down to temper
excuse me kids have got the fbi hats on
so this isn't long after 9 11. um
yeah so that everyone's a bit twitchy
around it
guy walks up says to the kid and the
kids are about three rows back but
they're in double seats sitting on their
own
we didn't want to sit with them have
them sit with us they were a pain you
know just oh can we have this
so and the steward system where'd you
get the hatch from guys because got fbi
had said oh my dad's just been out that
dad's just been out to quantico brings
over a bottle of whiskey he says we
welcome law enforcement
on usa
he's been my friend ever since
ever since wow and i still he still
lives in charlotte and i still keep in
touch that's cool that's cool yeah he's
cool it's cool but you know we're lucky
please please guys and girls are lucky
it is a great job despite the popular
media giving them a kick in on a regular
basis some of it is deserved
some of it's not um it's still a great
job
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]